inspiration can come from all sorts of
places some players simply strive for
the victory they feel they deserved for
years he just has to watch that c KCK
down this is it naie I've taken the
major other players want to make their
family proud and then just seeing the
seeing the game one games and how they
were going we were going for like a bit
more aggressive come and I'm just happy
that we managed to pull it up and some
just want to prove the haters wrong
before this a lot of people said that a
midl laner that played my style didn't
deserve to win the championship but I
think I finally proved it I am deserving
and I want to thank all of my teammates
and everyone that supported me Cara is
the best League of Legends support in
the world and his inspiration doesn't
just come from within now this guy has a
special place in his heart for his
favorite K-pop
[Music]
[Applause]
Idols so how does one of the greatest
league players in the world go from
crying on stage to standing his faves
before lifting the trophy why does
League's mechanical King Play support of
all roles and did Cara get to finally
live out his dream of hanging out with
K-Pop Stars oh my oh my
God come
true all right before we talk about car
I need you to check out our brand new
merch collection including our onward
and forward shirt over at shop.
thescore.com okay so if you have paid
any amount of attention to League of
Legends over the past couple of years
then you've definitely heard of Ryu Kia
minok he has been toted as one of the
best if not the best supports in the
game he is a trend Setter so there's
obviously like people you know there's
there's pocket picks there's people who
have a particular style but anytime ker
does something no one questions it
everyone just kind immediately starts
practicing it and kind of goes okay cool
we got to figure this out the the
Caitlyn bot Lanes any kind of the
Marksman stuff anything like that he
really just kind of brought to the
Forefront even the Senate choats it's so
exceptionally rare that when someone
does that you just kind of go oh that
has to be op because car he his presence
alone and his play style just makes it
make it op basically but it's not going
to keep the dive going huge in the early
game from blg to shut down this botside
combo they're going to keep the dive
carrier blinking heal bars might just
fish with the reset should oh that's an
Oban one you certainly cannot afford to
make you've definitely seen that clip of
him crying after losing worlds and he is
also a huge K-pop
St so how did our boy get his start well
born and raised in Busan South Korea
Cara first started gaming with surprise
surprise his older brother when he was
four playing games like Starcraft but it
wasn't until his Bros showed him a
madlife montage that Carri had decided
he wanted to pursue a career in League
of Legends carria looked up to the
support Pioneer and took to the role
instantly he quickly Rose through the
Challenger circuit before landing a spot
on DRX is starting roster in 2019 might
be a dead Blitz as the flash on in he's
trying to make the most of it and trying
to feed aiming as the ultimate's going
to come in he finally gets a kill but
chovi is going to put an end to that
Madness as now flashing away as Chi the
Olaf getting a lot of value here poit
coming on in carry a running away up on
the top side as finally the Olaf dies
and the stun comes in from Bard as Kuro
is also going to go down but now Z one
in the midst of so many weak members of
DRX is going to be able to take out the
CH but these B stuns are insane after an
impressive rookie year T1 picked him up
for their big rebuild roster this gave K
a chance to play alongside one of the
legends of the game Faker now it takes a
lot to get noticed by T1 especially if
you didn't come up on their Academy
roster but Cara was a guy worth noticing
see most mechanically talented players
gravitate to roles like mid or carry
where many champions demand intricate
mechanics and perfect timing that is
going to land but he does have cleanse
and even flashes away from that one
follow up trouble bubble trying to get
nasty here nearly gets him a flashes in
for the kill First Blood goes to Toby
but has he got too far no the misses toi
is going to Sid step and oti goes down
toi what a mad bad support tends to be a
role that's derided for being easy or
low skill one that's more about
communication and decision- making
rather than mechanics but K is so good
that he makes support Champions look
like carries we've had exceptional
supports but I don't believe we've had
so many at least in my in my experience
with the ceiling as high as his to just
kind of make everything work whenever he
needs it to work Gooma there's no one to
jump back on him and hil's the man
that's targeted down F gets another nisi
uses the out Glock just to BU some time
but Goa has done it once again JC with a
slicing melstrom gets at least a kill
back but mad lions are raced and T1 are
going to get the baron after that one
they rework oh kick
flash Jax's animations look kind of
smooth Kia oh
what
what what another arrow lands into a
full combo it's just a big chunk but
it's while they're also getting the
objective and they have Herald as well
so they can push in these BTA waves
Force thex oh my God Carrie are you
kidding me he just sets it up like it's
point and click during his time on T1
some people started calling Cara the
best League of Legends player in the
world which was crazy no support player
has ever been touted as the best so of
course Faker is the greatest player of
all time but right now I think K is the
best player in the world
but it wasn't just his mechanical skills
that were earning him fans Cara's
personality it was coming out more and
more and it turns out the dude was
downright
[Music]
Goofy
fore
speeech
[Music]
fore oh
I'm sorry Kio was bucking Trends proving
that Korean league players don't have to
be hyper serious stone-faced robots
which made him an instant fan favorite
and yeah this was right around when
Ker's proclivity for K-pop came to light
he obviously has a a very large love for
K-pop I think it just kind of shows that
for someone like him it's not just
always about the game and there is like
obviously fun to be had and there's
obiously more to life than just League
of Legends God forbid it's definitely
something that kind of again just brings
people towards him because it's not just
about the game it's showing that he is a
person he's a personality it turns out
that Cara stands Luna or whatever it is
the kids say these days he's a fan of
multiple girl groups and even promised
to do a tomorrow by Together dance if he
won lck summer in
and while K didn't win that one he did
bust out his moves the next year when T1
was riding High Point is our boy loves
K-pop almost as much as he loves making
you believe being a professional support
player is a real job and one of his
favorite groups is new
[Music]
jeans
and that's important because Cara's two
great passions collided at World's 2023
ker was out for Revenge after suffering
a heartbreaking loss in 2022 he was out
for Vindication wanting to prove that
the best player in the world could be a
support and of course he wanted to meet
new jeans who were going to be playing
the grand finals opening ceremony now T1
were not favorites going into this
tournament but Cara dug deep not only
because he wanted to win but because the
further he went the closer he got to
meeting his favorite band Baker stays
standing T1 stays standing the last
Light of the ltk bir bright and Busan is
they head to the semifinals despite the
doubters T1 made it to the semifinals
where they faced off against the
tournament favorites jdg T1 had been
working magic all tournament long but
jdg seemed too tough an opponent not too
many people pegged the Korean Dynasty to
make it to gr but every member of the
team wanted to win Kia wanted to meet
his idols and that passion fueled them
all T1 just need to weather the
storm and the heal is good in Lane but
once you get out it is very tough not to
have the cleanse St on the flank on the
side TP coming in fer looking to make
the play get rer OD goes in and again
the combos are clean the Hostile
takeover is damn well hostile T1 look
going to leave no survivors alive three
exited the entire team will get
absolutely nothing T1 in the clutch are
two damn clean owner zoning them away
2.5k is getting lower and lower they
will burn it down they get what they
came for T1 do they want to stay for the
fight knock up coming through owner
caught up flly and drag will take him
out to safety kavi burning on the back
side owner still standing with rer with
the lightning crash out trying to go in
but goes golden carry by bit more space
for the rest of the team arrows coming
in from the bars ruler incredibly low
but maybe just maybe he can turn it back
but Goa Still Standing Tall he can't
walk in a Range T1 starting to feel like
an inevitability ruler der not enough T1
are running jdg in circles in these team
fights single missst from jdg and team1
can instantly fully commit to the fight
it's the shock wave K getting lower and
lower falling apart under the pressure
jg's hope dwindling and taken down blg
they've taken down
LG it is not LPL versus lck it is T1
versus the LPL and they like those odds
as they move to
[Music]
finals look Faker might not have been
too impressed but our boy did the damn
thing he even impressed new jeans
themselves with his triumphant Cry of
Stan Victory so I already have their
merch a hoodie I already asked my stuff
if I can make it to the finals can I get
their autographs on my hoodie and the
merch and they were like yeah it's
possible so I'm so excited to get my
hoodie signed by new jeans heading into
the finals K even got to meet new jeans
they signed his merch and everything and
one can only assume that the sheer Joy
of meeting his K-pop Idols In the Flesh
empowered ker to reach his final form
because just a few short minutes after
he watched new jeans perform the lad
destroyed webo in the grand finals it
was pretty much the best day of his life
as for members are here teleport event
not available for the sh they dive in
the turret goes down the needle work
just rips the senator shred ASAS just by
himself destroying everyone hostile
takeover comes in light has the glans
but you can't L Death it's a triple kill
for Z and they'll get to work on the
inhibitor it might just be the game
right here ker is on that sideline they
know he's there yeah he flashes in he
finds himself the cham on to Fours there
is the ultimate from the shy but it just
doesn't quite do enough they try and get
out but Faker has the perfect execution
and locks down his fellow
ninja shiao now taking a whole lot of
damage in Faker he's in the Shroud he's
toying with him it's a double
kill and back in again it's a triple
four times T1 has lost in a Bame five
four times they've been knocked down and
four times they have got back up for
this moment it was s years since their
last a decade since their
firstt legacy has been
reignited T1 will be your 2023 world
champions Cara did it he made up for his
tragic 2022 loss with one of the most
dominant victories in world's history
but our story doesn't end there we all
know that world's winners get special
skins for their signature Champions and
Cara was really angling for a lux skin
where she would practice some new jeans
choreography during the recall animation
but Riot had other
[Music]
plans
look you can't win them all but becoming
world champion is a pretty big dub I
think that ker just definitively proved
that no matter who he was against what
he was against what the meta was no
matter how many things changed it was
always going to be him Cara's rise over
the past few years has changed the
entire landscape of League of Legends
with his insanely deep champion pool
incred mechanics and Brilliant
decisionmaking he's one of the main
reasons that T1 was able to win worlds
for the first time in seven years and
getting to meet his favorite band along
the way well that's just grav Cara shows
us that whatever may drive you whether
it's a desire to be the best to outdo
your previous efforts to meet your Idols
or even all three it's all valid play
your own way with your own motivations
because if you care more than anyone the
results will will
[Music]
come very limited experience yes he
wasn't the roster for all of last year
we get a little bit bit of a whoops slip
and slide y's like get me out of here oh
no